foreign
Charleston West Virginia what's up Ray
hey Dr John it's a privilege and honor
to speak with you today how are you sir
all right dude I'm fantastic and it the
privilege and honors a hundred percent
mine dude thank you so much for uh
giving me a buzz so what's up man
ah so thank you so much for those words
and I also want to thank you and your
show for helping me with a lot of things
over the over the time I've had
listening to you guys but one of the
things in particular is helping me to
understand the difference between
wanting to lose weight and get out of
debt and wanting to want to oh great
question lose weight and get out of that
okay so you owe a bunch of money
I do I do it's and it's all student
loans how much
at this at this point in time 170.
what do you do for a living
um so I'm a scientist and I work for the
states I work with uh police and
prosecutors and I help analyze the
evidence for them gotcha excellent so
you were
not making
um Private Industry money to pay these
things back in short order
in short order that's about right yes
sir
and I I hear your voice you're uh we're
not going to give away locations and
details and so I want to respect that
but also I've worked in both Private
Industry and in government institutions
and there's a vast difference in
in uh how they pay you so there you go
um and then tell me about your weight
dude
so as of as of today I am I'm at 300
pounds so I would say about a hundred
pounds plus somewhere around in that
range over what I should be quote
unquote okay
um so who gave you the should number by
the way
um the internet and
um Health classes and all that there's a
healthy weight to um height ratio and
Ray
you want to know the difference between
wanting to and wanting to want to is how
much time you spend on the internet I
bet there's a direct correlation
get off the internet and and I want you
to set up a a doctor's appointment okay
yes sir with the real human that will
look you in the eyes and take give you a
good blood assessment take care of you
and then say here's where you're at
and if you're a great doctor they'll say
here's where we're at because we're in
this together
okay all right so go to uh
so you've man you've dug yourself a huge
financial hole
um to use Dave Ramsey's language you
have a very small shovel because you're
a government employee
and
um do you love your work
honestly yes I do okay this is exactly
what I wanted to to do when I was
um
at the end of high school and into the
beginning of uh the schooling that I did
I really wanted to work in law
enforcement of some kind the police
routes didn't quite fit so I thought
being a scientist for the state working
with evidence did a lot better and I'll
tell you what I do think it hit a lot
of the marks for where I find Value and
purpose and work excellent excellent
okay so when you take me back to your
original question and the Genesis of
that question
sure so
I I feel like now I know what it means
to wants to lose weight and wants to get
out of debt and I've heard so many
debt-free screens now now like I can't
say that I can't do it or I don't
deserve to be debt free or lose weight
anymore I just can't I've heard too many
instances of people who are able to do
it
um but there is something I'm struggling
with and I'm hearing these stories of
all these people in their debt-free
screams to work five extra jobs and can
manage four to six hours a night of
sleep
um maybe actually getting two or four
out of that and with the family in the
mix and
Dr John I'm I'm wondering where all this
energy is coming from man
um
so there is a tremendous and there's
there's psychological studies here
there's tremendous
um
a couple different things here you've
heard the studies about learned
helplessness
have you heard that
I haven't there's some there's some
famous studies
um that could never be reproduced
nowadays because of
um laboratory ethics and things but
essentially they shocked
um animals I think it was dogs in the
original one they shocked animals
to the point of pain
and they didn't let them they didn't let
them out of their their enclosure if you
will
mm-hmm and so the the dogs became Frozen
and when they would intermittently let
them out
the dogs continued to fight and Claw
their way out when they're when they
were getting shocked when there was a
perceived No Escape
there came a moment when they just took
the barriers away there was no
intermittent they were free to go
and the dogs just sat there and got
shocked
and they they just said this is the way
this is
foreign
trauma it's a common experience in
people who
hate themselves
for whatever reason I'm not good enough
I'm always stupid I'm gonna always be a
whatever I'm the worst thing that ever
happened to me
this is just the way this is
and I've run in circles with people uh
myself included who have struggled with
body dysmorphia and working out and
eating disordered eating and being
overweight that's that's been the vast
majority of my life
and the correlation between I'm fat and
I am not worth being loved
is I think that's an a cloud that hangs
over our culture
does that make sense
that does and it sounds like you've been
reading my dirty laundry well so here's
another psychological
um point that I want to hit home
you are more likely to go through a
thing than you are sustainably then you
are to run from a thing
you are trying to get out of debt you
are trying to lose weight
you are not with a smile on your face
walking to Freedom
and those are two different they're the
same path
but they're two different processes
um my friend Sal DiStefano said two
important things he's with the Mind pump
guys two important things and it was
transformative for me just hanging out
with him and we were in interviewing
each other
um he said you cannot hate your body
into better shape
you run out of gas
you just give up you quit you get
exhausted you can't hate yourself to a
better body and the second thing is the
person who loves the journey will always
go further than the person who's
obsessed with the destination
and I butchered that quote a little bit
but here was the transformative moment
for me I became obsessed with getting a
number on the scale for so long and I
never weighed 300 pounds I've never been
obese okay so hear me say that
everything changed for me when I decided
I'm just a guy who takes care of his
body I'm a good Steward of my body
and that was a part of an identity that
was I'm going to be a great husband and
a great dad
and that meant I've got to have energy
to be around my wife and kids that meant
I've got to have energy to help around
the house and the only way I can do that
is if I exercise because exercise gives
me energy and the only way I can do that
is if I'm taking care of I'm eating okay
because if I just eat garbage all day my
my workouts are necessarily it's right
see how it all Builds on itself
yeah it does it does make sense but it's
when I quit getting obsessed with the
scale
now a scale is an important marker it's
a data point but it's not the end goal
it's just it's just a number on a
journey
see what I'm saying
yeah I do you have to decide Ray
can I just ask you this
um
man who told you that you're no good
[Applause]
Dr John elementary school kids are mean
man yeah they are they're ruthless
yeah and middle school kids are much
better no they're sophisticated and
ruthless and high school kids yeah high
school kids are just evil
[Music]
um
yeah
going through school feeling alone
and I didn't really have many I didn't
really have many friends I would even
just say many acquaintances let alone
friends
and I finally got a friend that from
high school after high school you know
what I mean
so he's actually one of my best friends
now ride or die
um but it was pretty lonely
what about a home in high school
um
mom
I grew up in a divorce household okay
um my mom loves me to death
um she did the best that she could
raising me and Mike me and my siblings
um all on our own
um
but
uh me and my sibling didn't quite like
each other either so
somewhere along the way you picked up
the message two things you're not good
enough
and you're never going to be good enough
the second you went looking for power
you went looking for power as being a
cop you weren't looking for power with
Advanced degrees
right I'm gonna show you
and
man
you've developed this idea that if
you're not that you have to be punished
for something and I don't know what that
is we could talk about that probably for
a while
but let me tell you man you don't have
to hurt
do you yo-yo a lot
over the years have you lost weight and
gained weight back and lost weight and
gained gained it back
I think you're reading my mail too Dr
John I've I've have been yo-yoing for
the last 10 years
so as soon as you lose a bunch of weight
and you start to feel good there's
something inside of you that says no
we got to be punished
we're no good
and that is the voice you have to that
voice doesn't get a vote anymore man
um because that voice has taken their
dad from their kids
that voice is taken somebody's husband
away from her
and I don't know whose voice that is man
but that's the one
is that fair
no it's very fair that's very fair
if you can believe that you're worth
loving
being loved and I don't mean that in
like the rainbows and gummy bears kind
of way although I dude I love gummy
bears
but I mean like you're like tell me
about it the um you have to decide
I'm worth not hurting
I'm worth
um
a life of joy and laughter and here's
the deal man you're gonna have to
practice that because you've never had
it
[Music]
you thought your doctorate or your
master's degree was going to fix you and
it didn't and you thought that one
friend was going to fix you and it
didn't and you thought the first time
you were going to be with a woman was
going to fix you and it didn't
Fair
very fair because that's inside of you
Ray
do you want that
I do I really do you promise because I
don't believe you you really do
yes sir I really really do like walking
to Freedom
now listen here's what this looks like
I made a bunch of promises to myself
this year
I made a bunch of like commitments I was
really like my wife and I went on our
annual Retreat we go on every year to
talk about who we're gonna be and what
we want to be about and what last year
was about where we're going and
yesterday Ray yesterday
I consumed twice my body weight
in so it started somebody left a thing
of brownies on my desk and I got back
from the holiday break and then there
was this little uh Snowman full of
marshmallow chocolate covered candies
and dude
I went crazy
and here's the difference this year I
felt terrible yesterday I have a hard
writing deadline I got nothing done I
was just a spinning out mess
and here's what I did
for the first time in my life I smiled
and said all right
I got tagged today
and tomorrow it's game on
and this morning I got up and I went
back to the gym
did what I needed to do was with my kids
I didn't go to war with myself I didn't
declare civil war against me I'm not the
worst loser ever dude dude I ate a lot
of candy yesterday and I felt terrible
and then today's a new one that's what
this is going to look like for a while
while you're practicing
not hurting
this crazy idea called hope
so tell let me hear it again are you 100
in
I am 100 in yes sir all right here's I'm
gonna give you
number one I'm gonna give you my friend
Dr Lane Norton's carbon app
it's the best coaching weight loss app
on planet Earth
okay it's the one I use it's the one
professionals use
and it will it's I mean it walks you
through calories and how the whole thing
works and it it like
um keeps track of your protein intake
all those kind of things okay
I'm gonna give it to you for free and he
is a great it's gonna be a lifetime
membership for free you never have to
pay for it okay but you gotta promise me
that you'll use it cool ah Dr John I'm
speechless hold on we're still I'm not
done I'm not done listen I'm also Gonna
Give You Financial Peace University the
whole class the every dollar app I'm
gonna give you everything
okay
I'm not crying Dr John you're crying man
listen I'm gonna give all of it to you
and here's the only thing I'm gonna ask
for you in return two things number one
that you actually use this stuff
number two that you keep me updated on
your progress
is that fair
it's more than fair okay sir thank you
um
you are worth being able to laugh you're
being able to you're worth being able to
roll around on the floor with your kids
you're worth being able to have a
reckless sex life you're worth thinking
I need to take a second and third job
and I'm I I but I'm too exhausted to do
it
can also tell you this you're probably
worth more than 65 000 a year you're
making
you don't believe that but you are
and I have found over the course of my
career I've got a particular set of
skills it's very small my talents are
very I guess you got one or two or three
of them
but they
are valuable in a number of different
Industries
and it may be that right now you've dug
yourself a huge 170 000 hole
I may need to go look and see if I need
to do something else for a season and I
may shock myself because that I love
that work too maybe not
but maybe
okay
actually still I'm gonna give you my
friend Ken Coleman's get clear
assessment too I'm gonna give you that
one also that way you can go through and
say is there another job out there for
me okay I'm gonna hook you up in the new
year
but we're going to turn this whole
sucker around is that fair
that's more than fair Dr John thank you
all right I want you to hear you say out
loud I'm worth being well
I am worth being well and I do not hate
Rey
and I do not hate Ray
dude
now you're on the path
it's gonna nah it's gonna suck man it's
not gonna be fun in fact it's gonna be
miserable because you're not only having
to budget your money and take a second
and third job and say goodbye to your
kids
and learn how to eat
um in a way that's healthy for you and
to start exercising not as though you're
gonna lose 30 pounds but because this is
who you are
that's gonna be hard but you're also
gonna have to learn for the first time
to stop hating Ray
you're gonna have to learn how to live a
life full of joy and optimism
and not a joy of misery and pain and I
got hurt and I got hurt and I gotta hurt
you're worth it my brother you're worth
it
Ray let's go make it happen